[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute
richtig hübsche apfel blätterteig rosen
die gehen total schnell richtig easy und
am ende sehen die einfach richtig hübsch
aus ich habe ja so viele apfel rezepte
offenen kanals hört euch die playlist
unten in der video beschreibung verlegen
genauso wie alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben und deswegen hab ich mir
heute das machen wir das ganz einfach
ich erstmal meine äpfel habe ich schon
gesäubert so werde ich erstmal den
inneren kern entfernen und dann müssen
wir sie in ganz feine scheiben schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die apfelscheiben in
heißes wasser gelegt ab zulässig da
zugegeben das bewegt einfach dass die
äpfel viel langsamer bräunen damit sie
auch noch schön aus den die können auch
zitronensaft nehmen aber ich habe
ausnahmsweise keinen zitronensaft da und
jetzt habe ich hier tiefgekühlten
blätterteig da könnt ihr auch
blätterteig aus dem kühlregal nehmen bei
mindestens wirklich mann der unterschied
das muss zehn minuten anschauen und dann
machen auch schon direkt weiter die
apfelscheiben sind nach einer minute
schon richtig weich das heißt ihr könnt
sie abgießen und einmal abtrocknen und
jetzt können wir direkt weitermachen
blätterteig ist auch aufgetaut ich nehme
jetzt hier noch eine zimt zucker mischen
mit zimt und äpfel das passt einfach
richtig gut zusammen verrührt auf einmal
ganz kurz miteinander und butter habe
ich mir auch schon geschmolzen ich mache
jetzt so dass ich mir diese blätter
teigplatten einmal noch so ein bisschen
feiner aus rolle und dann halbiert weil
sonst wäre mir das zu dick aber
eigentlich könnte auch selber
entscheiden ob sie lieber richtig schöne
dicke apfel rosen möchtet oder viele
kleine feine
[Musik]
der blätterteig wird jetzt mit der
butter bestrichen dann geben wir die
apfelscheiben an den oberen rand es
kommt noch zum zucker mit dazu und
anschließend einmal einklappen und
aufrollen
[Musik]
ihr seht es ist wirklich super einfach
und das ergebnis ist die jetzt schon
wunderschön ich werde jetzt noch in den
ofen schieben bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze wichtig ist dass ihr dann
immer vor heizt dann brauchen sie so
ungefähr 30 bis 35 minuten bis sie
goldbraun sind
[Musik]
das sieht richtig heftig aus ist dieses
als ob das so ein edelrestaurant wer
hilfe
der ist so aber ist doch so den ganzen
tag des eu-gipfels schick essen sonne
aber weil man für das was nach
wichtigste war ich bin gespannt so ich
habe so das gefühl das ist nicht so denn
weil es ist wirklich nicht jedermanns
sache mappus ich bin gespannt wie müssen
wir uns
also ich werde es nie wenn die auch
schon aber hinter uns was ich mache ist
man auf geschmack ich mag apple com wie
das weißt du ja apple komme ich mache
alles dafür waren ab das mag ich also
kalte äpfel mag ich nicht okay das ist
es doch liebend gerne auch nur ein
wenig feiern 50 uns glücklich feiert das
ich find das schmeckt so richtig leicht
also hat durch den blätterteig äpfel vom
baum ist ja finde ich auch das ist nicht
mag es warm ist wenn ich ehrlich bin und
noch schmeckt man apfelessig raus
weil ich mir vorstellen dass viele angst
haben ich habe nämlich apfelessig in das
wasser getan damit es nicht bereuen dass
viele sagen aber was meine äpfel essen
schmeckt bei der menge überhaupt wissen
einfach nach apfel
diesem jahr dazu
ich mag deine ideen also macht unbedingt
nach ich mache mir da zählt zum café das
übrigens auch manchmal dazu im café
können wir das und wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß und nach machen und dann sehen
wir uns sagte im nächsten match
[Musik]